let's start at the beginning when did  Kira first come into your life we  fostered her at four years  any news on our call date no no small  talk Jim just get to the point why don't  you sorry  how are you good day big day thank you  for making this happen  I'll be back at 4:00 to pick her up why  aren't you gone are you telling me that  this is an abduction case are you  telling me you've no idea where she is  the details of Carey's day are becoming  more complicated paper finder I need to  understand everything I didn't turn it  around Julie I really hope you are you  her sister's web for blow when running  on the 6 o'clock news  shouldn't we consider the possibility  for arts should I be calling my oil Inc  accorded under my door what's right I  did the right thing by a little girl who  deserved to know where she came from  I hate what they're saying about you  it's gonna get worse yet love  [Music]  you